تتواصل مساعي بعض المشرعين في الولايات
المتحده الهادفه لحظر وتقييد تطبيق تيك
توك بسبب مخاوف تتعلق بالامن القومي
واتهامات بالتجسس لصالح الصين هذه المره
يمضي مجلس النواب الامريكي قدما في اصدار
تشريع لحمايه المواطنين من المنصات
الرقميه الصينيه حيث باتت معالجه مخاوف
الامن القومي اولويه وفق تصريحات رئيس
المجلس كيفن ماكرثي ماكارتي قال ان
تصريحات مدير مجلس اداره تطبيق تيك توك
امام الكونجرس تضمنت معلومات خاطئه
وتضليلا بينما طالب مشرعون معارضون للحظر
الحكومه بايجاد دليل اكثر اقناعا على ان
التيك توك يمثل تهديدا للامن القومي غير
ان التزايد شعبيه تيك توك في امريكا يمكن
ان يساهم في خساره الرئيس بايدن للتاييد
الشعبي وخلق معارضه داخليه لدى جيل الباب
فالشركه لديها الان اكثر من 150 مليون
مستخدم في الولايات المتحده اي ما يقرب من
نصف عدد السكان في حين ان 5 ملايين شركه
امريكيه تستخدم تطبيق تيك توك للوصول الى
عملائها يذكر ان مساعي الحظر في عهد اداره
الرئيس ترامب لم ترى النور حيث خسر سلسله
من الاحكام القضائيه في عام 2020 عندما
سعى الى حظر تيك توك وتطبيق اخر مملوك
للصين